not feel VSAT encouraged Boris Johnson
dodging reporters as he left this South
London flap this morning a morning like
any other as he dashed to his car
without answering any questions yet it
was here shortly after midnight that
police turned up after a complaint from
the neighbors neighbors
it would appear who are no fans of mr.
Johnson next to the two parking tickets
was a professional-looking sign visible
on his car windscreen saying we'd rather
enjoy him as our neighbor than our prime
minister unnamed neighbors alleged they
heard a route between the Tory
leadership frontrunner and his partner
Kerry Simon's so bad that it prompted
them to call 999 The Guardian newspaper
which broke the story says it has heard
a recording in a statement the police
said they responded to a call from a
local resident in the se5 area in
Camberwell the caller was concerned for
the welfare of a female neighbor police
attended and spoke to all the occupants
of the address who were all safe and
well there were no offences or concerns
apparent to the officers and there was
no calls for police action all of this
on just the first day of the Tory
leadership campaign the two candidates
were appearing before local council
leaders with Johnson telling them the
hour is darkest before the dawn after
bruising council election results last
month while his competitor spent the day
focusing on what's to come next what we
want now for the country is someone who
can deliver us from this brexit
constitutional crisis and that needs
someone who is able to manage and
someone who is able to lead someone
who's got the vision and the ability to
deal with the nitty-gritty and I'm that
person
there will be no dodging questions when
he turns up here in Birmingham on
Saturday with his competitor Jeremy Hunt
for the first official hustings the
verdict will be up to the Tory
membership Sam Coates Sky News